da bin ich paraglider marokko war ja das
mache ich einmal ja ja dass ich das
einfach so in andere kulturen so ein tag
so speichert fotos immer noch in der
cloud echt jetzt alter verbiss dass mein
fotos sorry aber dann netzwerk ist
einfach zu leicht zu hacken danke
nochmal für deinen wlan passwort ja ich
kann einfach nicht alles ach du hast ja
besuch hallo
[Musik]
scheiß krone ich will mein altes leben
zurück so schlägt also immer noch in
erinnerung wie schön das leben vor
corona war reisen konzerte essen gehen
also ein paar wochen zu hause rumhängen
ist ganz nett aber es gibt nichts mehr
was ich noch auf netflix gucken könnte
ich habe alles für durch katastrophe ja
ich weiß ich bin am ende ja ich will
mein altes vor corona leben wieder
zurückreisen
shoppen laufen bei anja tinter die woche
ok geschenkt aber wahr denn wirklich
alles super stichwort klimawandel drei
mal im jahr zum saufen nach malle machen
wir auch damit weiter die beschissene
bezahlung von wirklich systemrelevanten
berufen und hier teda demo und der ganze
andere rechte scheiss das wollt ihr also
genauso wie vor krone was hat das eine
mit dem anderen zu tun
durch den lockt da haben wir uns doch
alle endlich mal gefragt was wir
wirklich im leben wollen
früher war alles besser
ich zum beispiel vom ist das büro da gab
es ja home office zuvor super der andere
und ich werde jetzt viel mehr zeit für
die kinder ja super siehst wir merken
auf einmal welche berufe wirklich
wichtig sind die altenpflegerin die
kassiererin im supermarkt brunner die
läuft nichts
der lehrer der die verpennte
digitalisierung aus baden darf und was
brauche ich eigentlich der ganze kram
den wir uns kaufen bereichert der
verglich unser leben ist weniger mehr
dieses rattenrennen der marktwirtschaft
das leben wir doch sogar ein privatleben
aus schneller höher weiter
am sonntag habe ich nicht auf dem radar
in abgezogen und genau das meine ich mit
excel-tabellen durchgeplante wochenenden
von der oft genug im krankenhaus endet
billigflug reisen zum paragleiten nach
marokko
aber wir zum kitesurfen leute so geht es
mir ja hefte raus klassenarbeit die
reichen industrienationen also wir
lagern unsere produktion in arme länder
auswählen dass eine andere für uns
ackern wie nennt man das ich weiß dass
alex entwicklungshilfe globalisierung
oder anders formuliert ausbeutung
billige waren werden um die ganze welt
geflogen ehrung für einen winzigen
reichen teil der weltbevölkerung oder
noch besser wir importieren menschen zu
uns ja damit sie die arbeit machen auf
die wir keinen bock haben wie zum
beispiel spargel stechen urlauber
spargel slacker schweine zerlegt alte
pflegen wenn die weltwirtschaft
geschickt abgaben bei der alle gerne in
jobs mehr da ist nix wird zum flughafen
wenn der klimawandel so weiter geht ja
dann haben wir alle bald nichts mehr zu
fressen
brauchen wir wirklich acht neue outfits
pro monat
ja meine mutter kommt in corona dazu
meine sachen zu waschen abzuholen
hier das sind nur ein paar fotos aus dem
letzten sommer das macht dem planeten
kaputt und sieht scheiße aus
das könnte man ändern wir zahlen was
drauf und die näherin in bangladesch
verdient mehr und andere frage ist es
wirklich lebenswichtig das ganze jahr
über erdbeeren und avocados so haben wir
sind nicht so bescheuert wie wir zu
erstellen ist unsere eine
lebensgrundlage wasser vokabel diät viel
und zwei wochen zu noch nächste stunde
sozialkunde ist die sechste stunde also
die krise trifft arme menschen schlimmer
als reiche wie immer aber das muss nicht
so bleiben ja dass zb die leute in
wirklich wichtigen job so wenig
verdienen das ist eine frechheit
wir brauchen noch gar keine diskussion
über eine gerechte umverteilung
das ist ein riesenproblem hier daran
gewöhnt hat immer ganz miese laune weil
ich ein q7 und q5
[Musik]
die welt muss ein fachgerechter werden
wie wäre es denn wenn ihr beide mal
carsharing macht oder ihr mit dem bus
fahren
[Gelächter]
ja meint das ernst ich weiter herz es
kann doch nicht sein dass die armen und
bildungsfernen familien nach der krise
noch kammer und bildungsferner sind
etwas mehr gerechtigkeit bitte so
hausaufgabe umverteilung jeder hebt 100
euro ab und gibt das geld einer
altenpflegerin
der mannschaft ist gemeint dass nicht er
du bist du bescheuert okay bis dann lebt
einfach weiter als wäre nichts gewesen
und lasst uns gemeinsam gar nichts
ändern
ihr seid einfach super freunde bitte
dass harry hole dürfen doch als
gesellschaft nicht so faul und ignorant
weitermachen ich würde wirklich richtig
gerne mit dir über eine bessere welt
reden aber auch gleich das bundesliga
was dich mach das nicht sonst nein bitte
nicht
[Applaus]
schon heute schon kann dann abonnieren
sie den weg zu den anderen videos und
war blumen gibt auch diese dass man
garten